[Music]
really yeah what's your middle name
Wow so what's your full name my full
name is Emma Cheever Wellman Emma
Cheever I'm achiever Willman yeah the
hot breath averse thanks for having me I
appreciate it yes what is Cheever a
family name what is so Cheever is it's
actually there's a really famous are
nice maybe not that famous there's a
author named John Cheever you ever heard
of him okay so definitely not that
famous he he is where I'm like loosely
related to him but I think it's just
like a very like New England European
New England's name and then Willman is
chairman okay yeah all sorts of famous
people and you're famous on the woman
side but John Cheever loosely the author
I haven't read any of this books but in
certain circles supposedly very well
respected but don't you have a cousin
that invented Magic the Gathering
yes I do so you're very famous so my
mom's family is big and yeah Richard
Garfield okay yeah he is he started
Magic the Gathering how did you know
that I know everything about you that's
amazing yeah Richard I've only met him
one time but I met the rest of his
family you know multiple times you know
that's so funny he knew that so he I was
always trying to invent stuff when I was
a kid like a very always like oh they
you know I always just a little like I
used to write into Ben and Jerry's about
ice cream flavor she's always trying
that stuff and when I knew that I was
gonna meet Richard cuz his family they
all live in Portland Oregon when I knew
that he was gonna be at this family
gathering at this point he was kind of
like a legend because he had been this
is actually good for comics here he had
been trying to invent a card game for
years
mmm-hmm no one believes in him he asked
everyone to give him five thousand
dollars and he said I promised if I ever
sell this I'll pay you back and a lot of
people were like no get a real job then
he sold it and now he's richer than
anybody ever so like my uncle Abe his
godfather is like if I had given him
that money like he's the people that he
did help
he paid back like 10 fold right yeah but
nobody close donated to the cause not
that I know I mean everyone everybody
that I knew was like what is he doing
he's a loser
he was like 30 mm-hmm I think he was
about 30 when the game started to get
traction what I knew I was gonna meet
him I was like oh me cuz I looked up he
was on the cover of like time so like
I'm gonna ask him aid to help me invent
something or be to just I was like
whatever he's worth he should just give
me a million dollars my mom was like you
cannot go near him if you're gonna ask
him for money that's insane like you
don't need you know you're fine like and
I was like so when I met him I didn't
say anything cause I didn't want to get
like kicked out of the situation hmm
but he is my he is my relative yeah well
you're big into inventions right yes
that was why that's why they were like
you cannot go near him cuz I wanted to
be I had all these ideas and I wanted to
be like will you help me what should I
do
so yeah I tried to invent two things
what I try to invent something called
the granny grip okay which is now most
people don't really love this one
I like that have you ever tried to have
you ever seen like an older person try
to get into a bathtub not personalize
this I once I saw my grandma trying to
get in the bathtub and she like weak
knees so I was like oh there should be a
grip she could put in her hands to help
her lower herself into the bathtub
mm-hmm so it's called don't slip
the granny grip and then it would help
old women old men get into the tub
okay so that I did never got any
traction for whatever reason and then
the idea that people did like was called
stop the scuff which is a clear plastic
material that goes on the bottom of your
pants and helps prevent them from
scuffing that I really tried to admit
okay
that I like I had like a patent pending
I really like I was all these young
inventors meetings I really tried what
happened to it
I sent the product prototype I sent the
design for a product prototype to a
scheme developer and this is that's like
literally why started comedy cuz
I was so into it and I was so crushed
when it was a scam developer I went to
see comedy shows to cope with it cuz I
was like I had this job I hate it I just
graduated I was convinced stop the stuff
was gonna be like huge mm-hmm so yeah
like convinced like I was already like
blowing people off like I read all these
books about like I read up the book
about uh the woman who invented the
Spanx I need so much man I was like oh
yeah I'm gonna be like billions billions
and it didn't work and I was like huh
so you just started watching comedy and
more like oh maybe I should do that
instead I had always kind of been
interested in it value it was like I
didn't know I'd always seen it on TV so
I had no concept of what the stage is
cool you see something on TV it does not
seem that attainable it's like some
person killing in front of like all
hyped up people so now I know now that
I've got to do things that are like you
know limited experience here but been on
TV that it's such a constructed setting
where it's like the audience is usually
super pumped up hyped up it's something
you said a million times before it's not
your average comedy show mm-hmm but if
you don't know that you're watching it
like oh my god I can never picture
getting there but when you start to go
watch live shows and some of them are
brutal then you're like I could do that
I can see myself doing that like do you
remember the first time you ever saw
someone like really have a tough set
mm-hmm the first short live show I went
to I saw that and that made it seem much
more like oh like I could you know I can
I can stand in a corner and have a lot
of people like roll their eyes you know
when I would see Katt Williams on TV so
but I started going to shows and then I
started just kind of it kind of took my
mind off of like hating every like being
upset and then I just kind of started
getting into it and that was in Boston
this is impressive awesome but I wonder
if if I hadn't tried it
if stop the scuff hadn't happened while
I was doing a job I hated and ain't cuz
I was boss to such a good comedy place
if all those things hadn't lined up I
wonder if I would have liked if still
found comedy I don't know so it all
worked out I guess it depends how you
look at it would you say Boston's a good
scene Atlantis I gotta say oh it's great
pretty good scene have you been down
here before I had never been down here
to do comedy but I met a lot of Atlantic
comics because cuz this is one thing I'm
thinking about I noticed in with Atlanta
like it seems like it's okay in New York
LA and then Chicago and Atlanta are the
two other main places and then like
Boston in San Francisco mm-hmm does that
sound accurate yeah I go with that
because I used to think Boston was
really Boston still is but like I don't
even know if they have just for laughs
auditions in Boston anymore okay
and when I was in Atlanta it was New
York LA Atlanta people and then like a
Chicago person maybe uh-huh so there was
a lot of it land and then I feel like I
just seal into comics all over the place
for good reason yeah that's why and I'm
still I'm staying here because of that
reason like it seems like a lot bubbling
here and yet I've seen you've been
jumping around in a few days you've been
here doing a bunch of shows yes so like
you think it's great also it's there's a
lot of different types of people here
which is always good because then you
can do you can like be in front of you
know more like conservative audiences
and more liberal or more urban or
whatever mm-hmm it's like a real hub of
stuff yeah plus I think Atlanta has like
big character I think they like put good
energy into the shows just from what
I've seen I think it's like it's just a
good like people seem like they like to
come out to comedy shows which in New
York the people that come to comedy
shows are usually tourists it's not
usually local New Yorkers Scott shows so
it's nice when you're in your city and
like the local people in the city
support mm-hmm New York must have been a
tough transition for you because you
moved there once and then like moved
back within a year right yes so I moved
there oh I went from Maine
really
to Boston they started comedy when I was
in Boston and then I kind of jumped the
gun I feel like I'm moving to New York
and because I was in Boston for two
years and I was like I'm ready to move
to New York and it's just really it's
just a it is really a tough transition
if I don't know what the but someone
because people will ask about moving to
New York I don't know the best I don't
know if there's any perfect time because
like if you move when you're just
starting out that's great because you
have nothing to compare it to so you're
like oh this just sucks and it sucks and
you don't think all if I were in Boston
or Atlanta be like better quality of
life getting better show you know it
would
so you just that can make it good but
then that can also be bad because you're
not getting to perform in front of real
people which is or if you get really
accredited in this city you're from and
then you move to New York then that
sucks cuz you're like starting over
right but you're not totally starting
over it's like you start over in that
you have to like kind of do a lot of
like really shitty things for a couple
months but then I think you go much
farther than you would have if you
hadn't like developed and gotten credits
in your city does that make sense yeah
that does make sense yeah it's still
getting better at comedy right wherever
you are so you can climb the ladder that
much faster if you're better right with
at least some skill set and also knowing
that it's not always like that brutal
cuz when you first move to New York it's
just it's just a tough city to be in no
matter what mm-hmm
so but now everything's kind of
different too because like you could go
from wherever you're at to LA you could
just you know say you've got something
that really like catches on it doesn't
matter where you're living yeah the
whole equilibriums all twists it out now
you can't see I'm wiggling my finger
it's all finger point all over the place
it's all different yeah and you can blow
up from anywhere with the internet and
everything some guy at Ohio because I
discover do something like cat dancing
thing right now
figure out a way to make it regular he
could be more famous than the funniest
comedian anywhere ever that does not
have a dancing cat easily and I actually
was sharp on here oh nice she's
hilarious
she's from Italy she's from Atlanta and
she was talking about having moments of
just crying on
the Train I haven't had that I don't
think I'm an emotionally frozen awful
person because it seems like you should
yeah healthier of her than me I haven't
had that at all I don't know what
happened in that year where you were
like I gotta get her back out of here so
what happened was I so okay my parents
when I was doing comedy were like this
is crazy what the hell are you doing and
in my I brought my mom to a show that
it's my dad every show he's come to was
like the best show he had like a
disproportionate like a mess up view of
comedy cuz he's always like say he went
to like five shows my first couple years
they're like the best shows I've ever
done mm-hmm my mom literally came to
diverse shows ever the works like the
one this one she brought me to we parked
behind the car with a confederate flag
on it we walk in this guy's talking
about raping Asian woman and it's okay
cuz their eyes already look weird like
literally saying that whoa people are
he's like destroying it's somewhere out
and row down my mom looked like she was
gonna cry and she's you have to promise
me you'll look at grad school please so
I looked at grad school and I got into
school in New York so I was there for
two years doing that when I was starting
out comedy there but I studied like
entertainment business mm-hmm so when I
grant media studies entertainment
business so when I graduate I was like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up because like I
was reading about like how you like
publicity and agents and managers and
how people become celebrities and I was
like man this is brutal so I wanted
Milla to it that's what I was trying to
like learn and there isn't really there
isn't like it's like you have to get a
lot of exposures or people who know who
you are and they have to gravitate
towards you like there's a lot of like
ingredients in the soup mm-hmm but it's
a crazy soup so when I graduated I was
like I have to try to see if I can just
try to do something else and then I
stopped for a full year and went back to
Boston full year Wow
I know it was probably the best year of
my entire life it was great when you
weren't doing comments yes
it was great like I caught up with
friends like I had like I had a job I
didn't really like but I was making a
work date at a ton it's great
did you also quit recently and think
about going into like management no that
was then that was that was that that was
the year no and then what what happened
was I missed it and I was just like you
know I would go in he's like I got this
job and then I would go on info
interviews about like thinking about
being an agent or a manager you know
like I was just kind of think about that
but then I was like I felt like I'd
always wonder what would happen if I
hadn't you know pushed it myself
and then actually this is crazy I went
back okay so when I went back to New
York I got fired at my job in Boston
through what I lied my way into getting
the shop selling educational trap now
the fact that I didn't get fired in the
first week is insane literally lied on
my resume I called a recruiter I was
like what kind of resin what kind of
what kind of resume can you get a job
for he sends me an example slap my name
on I go what do you know that's my
resume and he goes oh great and then he
submits me for a job I kinda don't do
that well on the interview I get a
second interview and they call my
reference who was my friend who's an
actress who pretended to be my old boss
she kills it so when I come back in for
the second interview that I Emma we
would be honored to have you she was
like I made it sound like you should be
President like she was like you she's
like I laid it on thick this was like
for a shitty little entry-level job and
I was like okay so I got the job mm-hmm
but I did that for the year and then
when I got laid off I like use that time
to like come back to New York but I
applied for I was on unemployment I
applied for an internship at a talent
agency because I was like should I try
to should I do what I really wanted to
go back to comedy or should I really
give a fair shot at being an agent here
said a lot of friends that were comics
so I would ask them what they liked and
their ages her managers or didn't
and I was like I'm gonna apply and I
applied for this agency I applied for
two agencies to be in the mailroom
got recommendations from comics one of
them was called this place called APA
and then I applied to one at Gersh APA I
didn't even get like an interview to
work in the mailroom and then I ended up
like signing then they I when I started
in comedy and they signed me on as like
a client and when I was in there and
they were trying to like win me over for
whatever psycho reason it's not like I
was talking to anybody else but like
they were like you know we really want
to work with you I didn't I wanted to
bake I wanted to work with you in your
[ __ ] mail room as agent assistant
like peon - probably you yell at the
person five rungs above me but I was
like so that was like a nice come around
thing that's nice and then I then they
dropped me right after Colbert and now
I'm actually with Gersh what I know it's
crazy they drop you right after Colbert
well I think they knew that I was maybe
again I was like starting to look around
on them and then they were like yeah and
then but now now I'm within a place
where I've never felt more like actually
really good about the people I'm working
with like they care and they're
proactive and like they have great
insight so I feel good I think a lot of
times in this business when something
shitty happens like oh my god how am I
ever gonna what the [ __ ] then something
else kind of happens and you're like oh
alright it worked out I wish I had done
so stress yeah I think definitely the
crest and trough
yeah the crest and trough exactly seems
to be a trend the time man but also come
out maybe it's like that in everything
though I don't know it's probably life
yeah it's probably yeah well it is and
they're like what you compare yourself
to other people they're like yeah I'm a
nurse I [ __ ] do that too and I'm like
you do yes special exactly it's so do
you think people are more self-absorbed
that get into comedy or you just have to
be self-absorbed by virtue of trying to
make something of yourself well
everybody is self-absorbed and
self-interested that's why capital
and failed because it is that's why I
failed that's what I mean like a lot of
economists predicted the end of
capitalism just because at the end of
the day we're all self-interested and
we're just gonna look out for us right
like the fight-or-flight response
yeah and greed had just gotten to a
point to where you know the bubbles hurt
that's why socialism failed is that way
well capitalism capitalism failed feel
like we're in the middle of capitalism
failing really wow you are good yeah I
studied philosophy but I don't know I
don't know anything I know like when I
think I know when I think something's
really wrong like if cat I could see
capitalize I'm failing right now
absolutely yeah we're [ __ ] it's an
exciting time Oh God
but not to steer back yeah towards
comedy break this is a this was a big
question interviewing you that I want to
know about was Colbert because you're
one of the few comics who have performed
on Colbert and you were on his live show
oh yes well like you you're one of the
rare to get on there but then also to be
on his live show I got a story for you
about that please okay so this is how
this happened
so I met this oh I okay so this is also
again the universe just kind of like
wiggling around so I had done a college
like that said there was only a
three-hour drive but he was more like a
six hour drive and I was really pissed
off about it so I went out there did the
school come back that day I'm like oh
[ __ ] I don't even have time to go back
take a shower I returned the car and I
like have an hour to kill before I go to
the Comedy Cellar I just gotten in there
mm-hmm
you know I was like I just like went to
the gap and like changed there I guy
feels so mangy and for whatever reason I
remember like having a really like fun
set and I was like oh thank cuz usually
afterwards I'm always like oh I should
have said that
like I said muffin I should have said
bagel like I'm an idiot you just like
the note you just obsess about this I
remember me I was really fun so then I
got an email from someone who worked at
Colbert
and she was like let's talk and then we
started talking and it was actually the
Booker as there's a new Booker there I
think she'd only been there like four or
five months she took over Eddie Brill
okay she's super cool she was like you
know I want to help we're gonna set like
it could take a long time it's a whole
process and I said okay so we just kind
of started talking and then I think it
was like maybe three three months later
that she actually oh yeah so she so I
was like Tom I'm doing an industry
showcase I was like come to that and I
remember it was kind of it was like I
was nervous she was there and you know
how industry showcases are very like
everyone's kind of like on edge yeah so
afterwards she was like hey like I don't
think of stand-up as a dog and pony show
like you can take me wherever you feel
comfortable it's not about showcasing us
about developing a good set Wow and I
was like who the [ __ ] are you I couldn't
I was like that was the greatest thing I
ever heard and then I took her to this
place like a real dive bar and I was
like can I work on my set here and she
was like you know whatever
like let's just art working on it so I
started working on it there at like this
like place and then my friend runs the
show and he's like is that the Colbert
book or like why are you bringing her
here I was like she said we could work
on it wherever and he was like all right
like I'll get her a nice seat like it's
like literally and like this like scuzzy
basement so we started working on the
set and it was a great experience like
they were like really they were they're
great they were like we don't know when
we'll get you on and then it was am I
remember there was a Monday and they
were like actually could you do with
this could you do it soon I was like
okay so we had it already I was I can't
let's do it and I invited like my mom
all might like some friends and it was
me and Bruce Springsteen so people were
like kind of like like all these Bruce
Springsteen's fans were there and when I
got there my car pulled up and the only
other guest is Bruce Springsteen so they
think I'm Bruce Springsteen so I
like crazy cheering and I was like
what's going on and a message the Booker
I was like like I just arrived and she's
like okay like there's a lot of Bruce
Springsteen fans outside just a heads up
and I was like okay so I'm like alright
that's definitely it is in there they're
like cheering cheering cheering I step
my foot out of the car and there was an
audible and then I got really nervous
and I didn't know this Bruce Springsteen
fans when they cheer for him they go boo
ruse I didn't know that
so someone starts going boo and I'm like
and I scuttle inside because I thought I
was getting booed I thought they were
booing me for not being Bruce
Springsteen and like attention I was
already like this is [ __ ] crazy like
how what am i doing so luckily what
happened was I ended up getting bumped
okay so I was like oh my god and then I
got bumped cuz Bruce Springsteen went
long and my mom was there and was like
this take us but can't I talk to someone
I told everyone you were gonna be on
tonight and I was like shh shh
like don't you're not talking to anyone
you're not complaining to Colbert that
like I wasn't on tonight he is no no no
no no but I'll put a lid in it than that
so then they were like okay come back
and you can come back on Monday and do
it on the live show and I was like okay
Wow so but I was so I was like I had all
the build-up for that Thursday and then
so it since that didn't happen then I
felt really I don't know not that
stressed out about the Monday and it's
interesting because people will be like
oh his live wasn't that crazy I feel
like since stand-up is always live I
didn't really think about that yeah but
um it worked out and like I was like
happy with it I was happy I guess I
don't know I didn't really think too
much about it being live how long do you
think it took you to develop a set to be
ready for that like a long time because
okay so when I met so they had it took a
long time because I had been trying to
make a set I think it was like maybe a
year and a half before that I spent a
while trying to make a five-minute tape
just kept on not getting the tape so
then I just was like I'm gonna put a
rest too and I when I was
auditioning for just relax that's
working on a five-minute set for that
mm-hmm
and then when I tried to get it on tape
there was always something where I was
like so it took a while like years
you're talking about yes and no because
it was basically just me like working on
material and then it took years working
on the material I ended up doing on that
gotcha yeah which is kind of
embarrassing but it takes that long
that's that's everyone though right
nobody just is like oh I'm gonna go do
my new five no everybody
yeah right everybody's doing like the
foundation just right that they know
like and I've been trying not to do
those since I did that yeah try not to
do that yeah which craziest they reached
out to you there's this hole just to go
late now you gotta email the Booker and
you got to have this agent in this
manager and then y'all got to show up
like a superhero team she literally was
at the show the Booker was at the show
and then she reached out and I and
couldn't have been more like cool like I
didn't feel it I don't know what the
process is for other places I don't know
if it's like that open but like yeah I
felt like really like they were working
with me and it wasn't like a hole also
when she saw me she saw me do a
15-minute set so it wasn't like I sent
in a five-minute clip and then she was
like here's what I want if you're gonna
do a five-minute set here's how I would
want that to go for our show and then I
kind of started from there I think if it
had been me sending in a five-minute
tape don't I feel like it's so anxiety
producer trying to get that tape yeah I
even know if I ever would have gotten
one together
it's very stilted and you're overhanging
every word and almost exactly exactly
I guess just for laughs worked out too
you were a new face yes so it all seemed
you couldn't get the tape but then you
get it anyway my auditions for jester
laughs were so fun and like had a great
time mm-hmm the actual just for laughs
was like okay so there was no tape from
that to be guys if anyone has the tape
of that please you can blackmail me no
it wasn't like but it's like the actual
year when you actually do the new faces
like it was odd I loved being there and
I did just for laughs Toronto this year
and that was so fun I wasn't doing new
faces at it but I don't know it's so
nerve-wracking when you do new feet we
build it up so much yeah but I think we
everyone performers just we all just
need to like chill a little bit and know
that nothing is everything but
everything something like that was just
a show that the Booker's on the air but
no nothing we can't give any one thing
all the Power was Colbert everything you
wanted it was that kind of disappointing
it's um it was everything I wanted it
was everything I wanted but also like
since I've been in New York like I've
seen so many people with late-night sets
that are it's like they're just doing
the same thing as everybody who doesn't
have a late-night set to I think if I
had been in Boston and someone had been
like late and I would be like oh hello
Hollywood like here we got my own teeth
like excellent can't wait to be like XY
and Z what would this like I felt like I
had very like realistic expectations for
it yeah like um I yeah I feel like there
was realistic X I think my mom like
afterwards I remember she called me and
I was doing the school now in the middle
of nowhere and she was like like really
out of the hill in nowhere and like I
was performing like a cafeteria or
something oh my god this is rough and
then my mom perfect timing call up
afterwards mostly cast your life changed
since you been on television like when
do you think it's getting like when's it
gonna click in and I was like no it
hasn't no it doesn't work like that
she's like well what does it work like I
don't know no I don't know I don't know
I don't actually know
but it did help yeah I guess it was like
empowering to do so
yeah I mean I've totally I've been
working on a five-minute set Conan was
my goal for 2016
yep and now that it's December listen
all right maybe 2017
exactly yeah totally or like James
Corden like there's like a lot of places
doin Seth Cohen is doing the most of
them homies doing the most but as soon
as I saw it Colbert start to do more I
was like I would rather do Colbert
because I think my material works more
for his voice yeah and Konan and also on
Colbert they give you an introduction we
don't do that on Conan Conan just shows
you he says this is so missing this and
then here they are I didn't know that
because I only watched the Conan clips
online he doesn't enjoy they may on TV
but online they don't read does have the
intro yeah I didn't even think of that
yes Conan come up and shake people's
hands I think so yes I did Colbert he
did yes but did you get to interact with
him like it was pretty funny yeah Rob
Lowe so the night I actually did it Rob
Lowe was the guest and um he like looks
great
like he just like looks like a movie
star so and I was trying to just kind of
be like a normal person so afterwards
Colbert came up he's really nice and he
shook my hand he was like he's like good
job and I was like thanks thanks man
like you too good job and then I was
like men Rob Lowe looks great and he was
like he really does and I was like yeah
good for him and he was like yep and he
was kind of like smiling at me probably
like what is up with this person and he
was like did you have fun and I was like
yeah I had fun odd did you have fun and
he was like sure yeah it was like yeah
thanks a lot bye oh wow yeah that was
our whole interaction I try to be really
like just treat him like a person maybe
almost to like a person like a pretty
man I was like hey thanks man thanks
follow me on Twitter yeah he was so nice
though so he was very yeah
you know I price should have told him
good job too but I really do think he's
doing a good job yeah he's doing great
really did you watch the election
episode not the one he did on he did
want to show time right he did all his
the night of the election was
interesting because he really seemed
like them speechless almost it's a
fascinating time it is gotta say you
think capitalism is gonna like explode
even more I would like to be optimistic
yeah
but then my instincts are like I feel
like we're not at rock bottom yet
I don't either I think we're not a rock
bottom and I think any maybe I'm in
total idiot but I think things are
probably gonna be okay
think it'll even out it will catch the
wake I think so okay I mean your
optimism but I don't know I I guess I've
been like kind of off the pulse like
when I go I feel like you don't see
really really fanatical people in
everyday life so I don't everyone I know
it's like pretty even-keeled mm-hmm so
then when they show people that are like
dedicating their life to like you know
something like this mantling Planned
Parenthood or something I'm like oh wow
like that's a cult serious very serious
group of people right really some making
some headway on that so the same thing
could be said people trying to dismantle
gay rights as web salutely it's like are
you active in that movement at all
dismantling gay rights I was when I was
in Boston I was like really into advance
here all the time for like when they're
doing marriage stuff in Boston I
volunteer for that I really volunteered
on Governor Deval Patrick's campaign
like so into it and then now no not
really but I've really this is gonna
sound like a like weird way about it I
really like shied away from doing like a
lot of like I've not really pursued gay
rooms or gay shows or gay anything and
I've tried to like I'll put a lot of
thought into like I would put a lot of
thought into being like okay wanting to
be like friendly and approachable
still myself but like not being abrasive
and then not being abrasive but still be
myself so it's like you know like I like
if I'm doing all these schools in the
south you know I'm not getting sponsored
by
the gay Student Union don't be like the
finance Student Union or the Asian
Student Association or whatever and
every now and then the gay Students
Association which is great too but I
feel like it is some form of access of
ism just like being in those type of
spaces and being like obviously very
like queer gay but not having that be
the main thing cuz I've seen something
when I see some gay comics that are just
like out of it like really like preachy
about it I really respect that but
that's just not me mm-hmm so they might
seem more activist see because it's like
I'm a lesbian but that just wouldn't be
the approach I would take does that make
any sense yeah it's interesting you
can't call that activism I don't know
but I do feel like I am in spaces that
it would not off the top go looking for
a queer person it's just like oh we're
gonna have this person oh she happens to
just okay whatever right yeah in Georgia
use University of North Georgia at a
military school mm-hmm and it was
awesome
like he was so it was a great show so I
don't feel like in some ways it's maybe
activism just by being in that space
just being vocal just being vocal yeah
like confident and pursuing your dreams
and right being free cuz I you started
off the first show you did was it like a
gay poetry open my yeah it was like and
it was like that was really fun as my
friends like gay open mic in this like
really gay area
it was just like like drag queens doing
poetry and then I told a story and was
like ah this is awesome
killing it and then I entered a contest
and it did not it was like it went from
like the friendliest space ever to
literally I got right when I went
onstage someone was like you look like a
boy which is even fine to say now I'd be
like yeah whatever but at the time I was
like oh my god and that's when I started
being like okay like I have to really
find a way to build a bridge here since
I don't necessarily like look like the
norm because you don't want it to be you
know I feel like a lot of comedy is like
your seat you want to fig you could be
friends with a person or you relate and
see yourself in the person
or you hate the person so much you're
like I got to see what they're gonna say
next
so I guess I would be more like friends
cuz I don't really see you know I do
look like I'll think about how I like oh
oh but maybe everybody does that too
like last night I wore a red shirt
button up red and I was like oh no I
probably look really abrasive so they
probably gonna feel weird when I get on
stage but they pride and even giving a
[ __ ] but I do you ever do that where you
wear something because I have flowers
you know right or they just didn't like
it and they're like it's not the shirt
it's your personality
okay fair it's not taking the approach
though I just want to be a person on
stage not lately but you've won like
certain with the New York publication
you won like top 10 like female comics
in New York but even being labeled a
female comic is that's like an you tried
it I'd rather that than be like the gay
con oh ok publication they did they go
the top 40 gay comics 42 like give it a
[ __ ] rest like just pick the top 5
top 40 right okay yeah honestly actively
there's probably only like eight out
there really doing stuff so where are
you pulling like the top eight and their
cousins like who are you [ __ ] are you
getting these people from so yeah I feel
like that bars can be kind of low mmm
okay and then with the women one know
like there's like a lot of amazing
female comics
amazing get comics out there too you
know who one of my favorite comics is I
love fortune femme so I think she's so
you should get a great attitude but
comedy is so subjective too so you
really can't it's definitely a very
subjective thing but no the woman when I
was and also anybody recognizing you is
also great too so I don't want to not
seem grateful for that I just something
in me gets like when I if it's just the
gay thing but that top 40 did crack me
up because I was like top 40
all right cool and I don't even know if
I was on that list I think I was
actually never been I hope so man yeah
you're number 42 it wasn't up 43 but we
caught you for a right fuckin'-a we're
parents something weren't so receptive
to you pursuing comedy what about you
coming out was that hang out couldn't
have been nicer like I'll congratulate
or you know whatever be yourself right
doing comedy they were like I mean get
it together my mom hates it hates it
she couldn't he she literally would
would rather me she'd probably like why
can't you just be transgender something
normal like she just wouldn't write
anything but actually doing stand-up but
I do get it it's a tough lifestyle you
know
so yeah the gay no problem the comedy I
figured they would be happy you just
weren't causing trouble yeah that I know
what the hell cuz I did get in a ton of
trouble when I was a kid like I always
was getting in trouble oh yes yeah I was
always getting in trouble and then like
what anything all my guts he thinks like
now eighth grade I used to do ASA
shoplift okay so you see that ninth
grade for no reason I just did it for I
have no idea why did it mean my friends
who so shoplift and then when I was in
high school I used to like drink'll like
I partied a lot it's a small town
there's not a lot going on so it's like
everyone's just like drinking beer and a
you know parking lot or a bush or
whatever and I was kind of homophobic in
high school too I didn't want anyone to
know I was gay so I made fun of the it's
not to her face but I always felt bad
about this I was kind of made fun of
this girl who's like openly bisexual I'd
always be Big E oh it's gross Wow what's
she doing and she did girlfriend she'd
hold hands on my hips Krauss why are
they doing that and people be like why
do you care so much no think I don't
know you just think it's weird
Wow how was that person is that when you
got kicked out no I got kicked out of I
went to a dyslexic prep school and I got
kicked out of that for like having say I
really did not want to be there because
my friends and from Maine it's like
really tight-knit community I want to
just be with them mm-hmm I got kicked
that a dyslexic prep school for like
having cigarettes
then I think on an off-campus trip me
and this other person like snuck beer
into a movie theater yeah so I was
always getting in like doing little
stupid things and then when I was in
high school like I used to like cheat a
lot in school and I think I got caught
cheating a couple times just like just
being a [ __ ] right you know but like
when I was in college or grad school I
didn't cheat but in high school a lot of
cheese that's how you got into college
yeah but then once I was there I didn't
need to cheat right it was high school
but yes I was getting in trouble and
then I right yeah even guy even got in
trouble I didn't get to go to my high
school graduation I got suspended I was
like with my friend Tom and we were like
we had been we were at like we're about
to graduate party and I had this beer
and I remember I was driving and I was
like put the beer in my backpack
so it's not in the car we're definitely
under 21 high school so like 18 senior
year like graduations in a week put the
beer in the backpack then I forgot about
it last day of school whatever you go
and you practice marching we practice
our little March and I go and return my
books I leave my backpack in the
gymnasium the next day I got a call
being like you left a backpack full of
beer in the gymnasium and they were like
is this your beer and I was like no and
then they're like well whose is it I was
like I'm not playing I'm no I'm not
involving anyone else I was like yep and
they were like if you tell us where you
got the beer you can still go to
graduation and I was like nope they
suspended me snitches I'm not sneaky
I'm not gonna get my friend's brother
who like already didn't want to get US
beer anyway in trouble see I'm still not
saying his name no way it's going to the
grave but so I got like that was like a
lot of trouble I don't get to go to my
graduation
so is that what mom washes her mouth
that was soap she was she was just like
what the hell yeah what the hell you
left a backpack of beer in the school
auditorium what about dad you've been
referencing your mom a lot what my dad
was just like he
was just he was like kind of just like
dumbfounded I remember though I remember
right up to graduation I was like can
you believe I'm about to graduate and he
was like well you haven't walked down
that aisle at yeah he's like let's see
what happens
that's what trouble I used to get it Wow
and I did student government so I was
like the vice president of the class and
didn't get to go to graduation Wow vice
president and the troublemaker yes and
your dad being the mathematician is like
it doesn't add up yet let's let's wait
to see the final product here impressed
with your research yeah my dad's a
mathematician which is also part of my
cheating my dad didn't realize that he
did all my math homework from the age of
he didn't really thought I was learning
I was just kind of letting him do it so
I would get like hundreds on the
homework and then on the 10th in school
tests like 20s mm-hmm my dad was like
well she clearly has an anxiety problem
you know she gets stressed out I'm like
no I just don't know anything he's like
no you're very impressionable she's very
sensitive my dad kind of babies me a
little bit I think but they're happy now
yes my dad my dad is into the comedy
okay I think my mom still you know cuz
there are a lot of hot you know and then
there's stuff like where she's just
always like you know it's hard to keep
track of what's going on which it is or
like I'll have you know a project that
I'll be like pitching around and say it
doesn't get picked up or like I shot
pilots before that didn't get picked up
and like there's just a lot of stuff
where I'm like if you start to tell
someone and it that you know you could
get an opportunity it doesn't mean it's
gonna go anywhere morals the story
exactly yeah so yeah but now I mean she
I think she's a little bit happier about
it now we've referenced highs and lows
in here no I would love to kind of
dismount here maybe on a low perhaps
they salute Lee this is something I ask
all my guests on here but you which
interesting thing about you is you also
enjoy doing urban rooms sure as well
yeah and you may know and I I do as well
and something that may come with doing
urban rooms is getting booed perhaps I
haven't had that
every room but I know exactly what you
mean but also I'm just gonna say that I
probably only just haven't done enough
of them okay yeah I give me a couple
more and I'm sure I'm trying to think if
I have good I haven't but that is just I
haven't I love doing them but yes that's
totally a thing yeah what about an epic
bomb yes oh my god the worst - yeah okay
and I love urban comedy like I was
thinking about it I think that said
Urkel entertainer is one of the most
like obviously he's very successful but
I think he's almost one of the most like
under appreciated comics like he's funny
yeah he's great I really like Cedric the
Entertainer I really like Bruce Bruce
like I really like those guys okay the
worst prom oh man
okay oh okay well I had one that was
like probably just the most ridiculous
but it wasn't the worst feeling because
it was just ridiculous for everybody can
I tell you to make it real quick yeah go
ahead yeah okay the worst one that was
the most ridiculous the most ridiculous
was my friend asked me to do a
fundraiser it was like 4:00 in the
afternoon and it was for an organization
for someone who had just died mmm I was
like I think the organization helped
offset funeral costs so we get there and
everyone is clearly in mourning and I
was like that they want a comedy show
and they're like the guy that I'd loved
comedy so we're doing it for him no one
wants to do it so the first person gets
up and it's like you know we basically
we can't pay for the funeral so we
really need you guys to support right
now help pay for this funeral we can't
believe he's gone your first comedian
has been on access TV I've never heard
of that I'm not sure if it's a thing but
that's what she put down from her
credits oh my gosh god I miss David
here's and then that and then I was like
and then right when I went on I was like
I can't believe that this is awful like
please like my condolences to David and
his family and people were just like
yeah then I was like so like it was just
a [ __ ] mess yeah it was just a mess
nothing I remember my friend Robin went
on
I actually did pretty good oh just like
kind of she just like what she didn't
start with my condolence it's like she
just went and did her set right like I
was too in the moment of the death right
but Abraham that like really it was a
bomb that boom like it was like I
remember I went on this is maybe two
months ago it's probably my favorite
room the Village Underground I love one
of them like I love that room and like I
remember everyone what like I was just
really off that day and the three people
before me were really killing it and
usually that room is like a great mix
for me but for whatever reason I really
just like was all over the place and I
bombed and then and I remember I think
when you don't do well it feels the
worst when you're like oh that was a
hundred percent mate yeah like that
other situation it was like yeah I was
like a funeral like that of course
mm-hmm this situation it was a hot crowd
comics for me were great and I just
dropped the ball and then especially if
you had like if you hadn't had a really
bad set and a little waiting yeah
they're always waiting in it and I was
like oh why hear anybody yell or say
anything to you after the show they
didn't but it was bad okay but I have I
mean the worst thing is if someone goes
[Music]
have you I mean I've been booed before
really the actual room was called taboo
so huh that's my bad going there right
up town shut the lights off on me like
really yeah it happens that's so
interesting but it's always good for you
I find bombing interesting and like it's
almost a behind the scenes of comedy
because most people see comedy like you
said polished on TV yes yeah I don't
know the struggle right and everybody
everybody thanks everybody everybody
does and especially when you're at
places where you see people that are
really famous like working out material
around I remember because you'll see
people working out material around New
York and it's like Seinfeld said in the
documentary comedian he's like the first
minute if you're famous like you they're
just like in do it like that you could
say anything he's like but after a while
you know if
doesn't work then they'll let you know
that too and that is true and it is
interesting you probably see it all the
time and you've seen it it's really
interesting about them but it's all God
isn't that like good in therapeutic yeah
it's granted someone who's like that
famous like them something not
connecting is okay a whole different
like they're still on such a higher
level that it's like but it yeah they're
trying stuff out evens the playing field
yeah and you're like oh yeah this no
matter what gotta be funny yeah and no
matter what no matter how funny you are
it's still a process figuring out how to
say stuff and all that yeah so where do
you as we close out here you know where
do you what are kind of your goals and
everything Colbert had to be a huge one
but that was a goal for sure what else
you got that's hip-hop involved in this
as well well I mean I love I would love
to do something that's like a music
countdown thing but my focus right now
is I had been work I'm is trying to sell
a show okay so I've been working on it
for about a year I've been I mean I've
been like you know such a process of
like you write different things then
some things rise to the top and what
you're pitching but I've been really
trying to get better at acting like
actually learn how to act
mhm which is hard but trying to do that
and then yet just try to get it you know
get a TV show it's your own TV show yeah
well you've being on the agency side and
the talent side do you have any insight
for comedians that may be listening in
to maybe how they can help their career
in one way or the other or just anything
you've learned I wish I didn't I wish I
didn't like I mean it's easier to say
that I wish I didn't quit I want to say
I wish I didn't stress out so much about
the process but then also I feel like I
in relationships with people bit why are
you like stressed out about so much and
it's like yeah I wish I couldn't go back
and been like like after just relax I
wish I can go back now and been like be
easier in yourself like you know what
did you expect was gonna come from that
it's just like good it's just another
thing like I'd sure I wish would go said
go back and be easier but then it's like
but then if you're easier in yourself
would it like push you to then like
really try to like create something at
and
thing basically like everything I have
like ever like really got was cuz I like
tried for it like because people when I
first got a college agent people like
how'd you get a college agent and I was
like well I when I got a good clip I
reached out this up so you you can't
just blindly reach out to a talent
agency like they can't even accept
submissions not from referrals but a
college agent you can they're much
smaller operation so there's always like
a way to get to what I mean not that I
have what I want but there's a way to
like figure out how you know things are
I think a little bit more in reach then
sometimes we think I think okay I think
this is what I got it
it's important to remember like the
industry side of stuff like they need us
to like when I go if you go in an
audition I'm always like oh okay I got a
you know I you know I almost think of it
like the casting director is I don't
think but you're actually on the same
team as them because they're stressed
out too because like I gotta [ __ ]
find some person to fill this role and I
get my commission if I find the person
so they want you to be the right thing
so same with someone who on the industry
side stuff like they want you to do well
and be good and all that stuff they're
not and if someone makes you feel small
if you and you really believe in
yourself just like know that they like
come around eventually or they're not
worth your time yeah exactly
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
I am gonna start a mailing list so if
you go to Emma comedy comm I have had
that up for a year haven't sent anything
out this holiday season you're gonna get
a really dyslexic [ __ ] brutally spell
happy totally PC I'm covering all the
holidays mailing list thing I'm gonna
send that out so if you go to my website
I would love to send you a mailing list
thing but no pressure
alright in the woman thanks for being on
hot breath absolutely yeah yeah no one's
ever not about babe I mean the Richard a
name magic oh yeah and yeah you're
interning at the rep
yeah yeah
[Music]
I breath